und das hier sind Bilder die unser
Kollege Dimitri säubel uns gerade
überspielt hat von der russisch
georgischen Grenze vom Grenzübergang las
vivo Moskau offenbar versucht fliegende
Russen an der Grenze zu rekrutieren die
von Präsident Putin verkündete time
mobil machen treibt nämlich aktuell
etliche Männer zur Flucht nun versucht
der Kreml offenbar manche von ihnen noch
einen Grenzen einzuziehen dimitriole
oder das Geschehen für uns ein wie ist
die Lage aktuell bei dir vor Ort Dimitri
alleine in den letzten Tagen sind
alleine 20.000 Russen vorwiegend Männer
an diesen Grenzübergang lassen passiert
also wir sehen jetzt hinter mir die
georgische sprachauflage
ist ein Berg und da fängt schon das
russische Territorium an an dieser
Stelle warten jetzt immer noch über 1000
Männer also Vorgehen Männer und auf
Einlass nach Georgien und es werden
ständig neue Vorschriften gemacht wie
sie nach Georgien rein dürfen zuerst
wurden nur Männer die zu Fuß gegangen
sind reingelassen jetzt werden nur
Menschen die in Autos sitzen
reingelassen und das ist permanent hier
kommen wir sehen das ja auch hinter mir
kann man dann kommt ihr Autos an einige
Russen die es geschafft haben es
geschafft damals die noch zu Fuß über
die Grenze gehen konnten warten jetzt
auf ihre Angehörigen die eben im Auto
sitzen und teilweise 30 Tagen
übernachten Sie auf den Parkplätzen auf
dem Parkplatz hier an der an der Grenze
und warten ihre Familien nach Georgien
dann endlich mit ihren Autos geschafft
haben und dann weiter zu reisen was
sagen die Russen die über die Grenze
kommen konntest du mit einigen von ihnen
sprechen ja wir konnten jetzt mit
mehreren bereits sprechen die
Entscheidung definitiv Russland zu
verlassen war bedingt durch die mobil
machen die durch die teilmobil machen
weil wir jetzt inzwischen wissen dass da
jetzt nicht bei diesen 300.000 Männern
hier ursprünglich offiziell verbindet
dann einzuberufen bleiben wird sondern
wahrscheinlich schon über eine Million
sie haben Angst sie haben Angst in den
Krieg angezogen zu werden bislang muss
man ja sagen dass dieser Krieg genau an
vielen Russen vorbei gegangen es war im
Fernsehen immer zu sehen was zu sehen ja
es wurden zwar westliche Sanktionen
verhängt aber die bei der Mehrheit der
Bevölkerung sich noch nicht bemerkbar
gemacht haben und gekämpft haben
Vorsicht natürlich Überzeugungstäter
sondern sie so bezeichnen kann und
professionelle Soldaten
von diesem Krieg und jetzt jetzt erst
realisieren diese Männer das das ganze
jetzt betrachten könnte dass sie jetzt
in den Krieg ziehen müssten und sie
haben die Flucht dann dürfen sie haben
mit ihr Land verlassen sie haben jetzt
wohin sie haben sich auf den Weg gemacht
nach Georgien das ist auch ein langer
Weg also wir haben jetzt ein paar
Menschen mit aus Moskau oder St
Petersburg angetroffen die seit vielen
Tagen unterwegs waren mit ihren Autos
standen viele Strauß um endlich jetzt in
ihrem Georgien zu sein wobei natürlich
auch gehen Georgien sie wissen natürlich
nicht wie was ihr erwartet dieses Land
ist ja auch ein sehr armes Land und es
wird sowieso schon viele Probleme und
deswegen weiß man nicht was was wird
jetzt gleich auf Sie zukommen deswegen
bestimmt auch Ungewissheit dieser Männer
was Sie jetzt gleich erwarten würde was
sie auf sie zukommen würde wie groß ist
denn jetzt die Angst dass Putin
tatsächlich die Grenzen dicht macht
die Angst ist Großstadt deswegen geben
sind so viele Männer die Menschen also
die Männer die mit dem ich mich
unterhalten konnte die haben wirklich
das war
Entscheidung sie haben Taschen gepackt
und eben sich entschieden kurzfristig
innerhalb von wenigen Stunden jetzt
müssen wir das Land verlassen weil wir
eben Angst haben dass wir gar nicht
rausgelassen werden und als sie dann an
der Grenze standen und dann sich
wirklich dann die Angst weit machte dass
mir ganze komplett nicht gemacht wird
aber vor auf der russischen Seite ist
ein Kilometer langer Stau dann haben
sich eben entschieden weil sie sich von
dem Familien zu können die Familien die
Frauen die Kinder sitzen in den Autos
und die Männer weil sie Angst hatten
eben nicht mehr rausgelassen zu werden
sind dann zu Fuß gegangen über die
Grenze und warten jetzt eben
bis ihre Familien dann jetzt über die
ganze eben reinfahren können
herzlichen Dank Dimitri Seidl an der
russisch-georgischen Grenze danke dir
für das Gespräch
[Musik]